et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis plymouth au royaume uni avec
patrick et nine scène expert en
relations internationales fondateur du
site toualy one century ou ailleurs
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir patrick kane une scène
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors ce sont évidemment des
accusations très graves et qui repose
exclusivement sur des sources anonymes
pour la plupart issus des services de
renseignement américains pourtant elles
ont été reprises dans de nombreux médias
ce n'est pas la première fois
c'est une tradition à washington sa
chance sur 1,5 million donne des
informations à tes journées importants
comme leur talent sous le washington
post des sources anonymes souffre la
tribu des événements accuse entités en
l'occurrence elle a reçu l'un catcheur
müller et le processus de destitution
était fondée sur les mêmes stratégies
quand même au sein de la miction trump a
même si la tradition remonte à un viol
important donald trump a déjà bien connu
cela et je pense que beaucoup
d'informations des services de
renseignement à la maison blanche
évoquer le sujet il doit savoir que ces
accusations sont présentés par les
services de renseignements et pour récup
à être fonte et en l'occurrence il ya
les implications géopolitiques forme
tout d'abord cela dit souad et donald
trump de continuer le processus de
détente avec la russie en tant que par
exemple les nouveaux traités darné
renégociation des traités nucléaires
entre les deux pays pourrait être
interrompu pour y avoir un accroissement
des tensions
et cela également un impact sur le
processus électoral et avec notamment
par exemple les militaires cardona
trucks va devoir choisir la russie où
l'armée et pourtant il essayait de se
présenter comme président promu terre
donc cette union est un sujet
d'actualité
conçu pour acculer une fois de plus de 1
quand j'ai d'autres sujets d'actualité
comme par exemple tout ce qui tourne
autour des ruches à gates comme de ce
facteur pourrait si la russie redevient
le fantôme l'épouvantail cas rarissime
remplit un vide le vide est le numéro un
mais de toute évidence cette histoire
est très légère
tokyo et ce sont les photos qui sont
cachés derrière qui veulent continuer
l'occupation en afghanistan tous ont
passé le temps la russie foudre est elle
qui m en grâce des politiques qui
maintiendrait la présence des etats-unis
en afghanistan c'est vraiment contre
intuitif et pour moi c'est surtout de la
fiction donc si on vous suit bien à qui
profiterait ces accusations il ya
plusieurs quand vous l'avez expliqué les
pros les contre la matière même ganis
temps il ya aussi en tout cas ça c'est
donald trump qu'il dit l'opposition
parce que il faut le rappeler est
évidemment le timing tombe
voilà un moment pas aux panneaux dans à
quelques mois la présidentielle
américaine starz avoir un esprit le
contexte est au prix de cette histoire
avec la russie fut un petit job c'est
d'actualité en quelque sorte les états
unis sont encouragés à adopter une
posture agressive envers la russie
les monts
y'a américains se livrent à ce genre
d'opération a régulièrement les services
de renseignement un produit des
histoires des sujets mais mieux
justement à la russie c'est vrai
également à la télévision et on les
retrouve dans tous les grands groupes
site américain il y a à la cia il ya le
conseil de sécurité nationale qui a
construit toute une histoire plus
concernant le gel de transferts d'armes
vers l'ukraine est assez de déclencher
justement cette destitution
donc cela ne devrait surprendre personne
mais il s'agit de couvrir un thème plus
général
l'année dernière on a déclassifié
certains documents sur la commission qui
montrait que sept huit ou neuf ans
auparavant les états unis savaient déjà
que la guerre en afghanistan était un
échec il devrait se retirer
ce n'était pas ça n'a pas été une grosse
histoire le washington post l'a évoqué
l'année dernière oui c'est très
important au vu du nombre d'années que
les états unis ont passé en afghanistan
avec le coup militaire et humains ainsi
qu économiques que cela représente
on résiste à l'occupation et
effectivement c'est une résistance que
l'on pourrait trouver dans n'importe
quel pays
bombardier est occupée mais on essaie de
détourner l'opinion de ceux là et on
parle maintenant d'organisations
terroristes
donc cela flatte certaines portions de
l'auditoire américain mais ce sont elles
les etats-unis qui ont créé la situation
avec l'opération cyclone ce temps les
années 1980 afin de chasser la russie de
la région et le lou jatteau s'est
rapidement transformé dans est devenue
ces mouvements des talibans et de
l'al-qaïda donc c'est vraiment généraux
liés au niveau historique et cela
devrait
faire les gros titres mais c'est le
travail des propagandistes il essaye de
créer de nouvelles histoires afin de
cacher ou de détourner l'attention de
deux thèmes beaucoup plus fondamentaux
sur le long terme
merci beaucoup patrick nsn d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rt france et de
nous avoir apporté votre opinion sur ce
sujet merci à vous